[Applaudissements]
peur je vous offre baba 17 jeux et
regarder c'est vraiment les développeurs
qui ont fait ça pour vous c'est
exceptionnel 1 regardez on dirait
[Applaudissements]
non
non c'est non
[Applaudissements]
c'est non c'est non en version 10 10
ces normes mamadou seck saborde hachette
a du sel dans les assiettes
c'est magique et atteint 2 dvd d'intérêt
au thorax est vraiment servi voilà les
mamies irish en rien n'est fait j'en ai
assez des stocks est d'y aller doucement
tout ça les mecs qui ont fait ça mais
non merci alors oui c'est un gros cadeau
qu'ils ont des femmes à merci pas besoin
d amour merci beaucoup à donner à deux
marches et un gros dossier des mains
[Applaudissements]